foreign
spoilers show I'm your host Paul and The
Sun Shines on us again brother as the
first trailer for Thor love and thunder
is now here it's time to Ragnar rock and
roll so follow us as we go through
everything you need to know about the
movie the Easter eggs hidden details and
things you missed ball spoilers ahead
for what happens in the comics and
whilst marble never completely adapts
storylines I'm gonna tell you tip off
ghost if you don't want those things
ruined please hit the Thumbs Up Button
if you enjoy the breakdown and make sure
you subscribe for the channel where you
have to hand it to us that the worst
puns make the cut and that's how we get
the paper Little Rock Paper Scissors
joke there and without the way thanks
for clicking this now let's get into
Thor love and Thunder
now the trailer very much opens with a
montage and thought talking about how
his hands are now used for peace there's
very much this 80s training vibe to it
in the same vein of Rocky and this whole
movie seems to be paying tribute to the
decade he starts off by running and we
watch through the magic of Montage how
he ages up this includes his classic
costume which looks amazing and we can
also see him meditating on a planet
which I believe has three sons Two Moons
and a saturn-like planet though trains
away using chains instead of ropes and
on his hat we can actually catch the
classic Avengers logo with the writing
strongest over the top of it this is of
course nod to Ragnarok when he called
himself that and said that the Hulk
wasn't now though it looks like he's
very much been on a wellness Retreat and
the guys lost all a dead weight like
screen Crush when they let Ryan Airy go
and allowed Doug to run the channel
getting a lot of hippie vibes from this
and we also see Stormbreaker planet in
the ground the handle for the ax of
course came from groot's arm and thus it
makes a lot of sense that he'd Planet
back in the ground now the Guardians
show up and alongside their Muslim blue
alien creatures these are potentially
the antidites who have being touched
upon in the Marvel expanded universe
they were first mentioned by ladysef and
the Agents of Shield episode that she
appeared in and we do know that Jamie
Alexander will be playing her once more
in the movie now interestingly the
Guardians are all there minus Gamora
showing that they still haven't found
her if you cast your mind back to the
ending of Avengers end game then you'll
remember that she was brought across
from Another Universe and quill was seen
attempting to search for her at the end
of the movie it was even theorized that
with her being part of thanos's army
that she might have got snapped away
however a deleted scene showed her
leaving the battlefield after Stark
carried out the Snap so she is still
alive but I doubt she's gonna pop up in
this movie and instead I think it'll be
something that's probably just addressed
in Guardians volume 3. now we catch
though wearing a red sleeveless jacket
and we know from the toy leaks that this
will be called ravager Thor ravages are
the group that quill belonged to and
they of course wear these red leather
jackets what about this costume itself
pulls from Thor thunderstrike in which
he also had the boots on really nice
corporate cohesion there where you're
taking already established character
design from the comics and tied into the
universe where it's also the uniform of
a group of characters that he's
traveling with now saying that the
Guardians might evenly without him as he
seems to get a boat and he even turns
around and walks away whilst they take
to the sky they travel through the hex
points that have showed up in several
films and this allows one to jump Across
the Universe at this point we see a ship
being pulled from new Asgard with two
goats on the front which are quite
important now these goats actually pull
from Norse mythology and they're based
on tangren is near and
Gardens
moving on in the tales of Legend they
would pull Thor's Chariot and they were
actually introduced in the MCU all the
way back in 1976. the pair were renamed
to tooth grinder and tooth gnasher for
reasons that I'm guessing you can
probably figure out for yourself and
they too pulled my guy's ride on the
boat we can catch Valkyrie and also Korg
standing there with first shoulder pads
it very much looks like they're sailing
across the universe and having fun due
to the cocktail party sign and you can
catch Stormbreaker firing out AI Frost
which we learn a cartoon Infinity War
this means silken pretty much travel
across the entire universe and it looks
like he's gonna stand on the front of
the boat and fire this across the Stars
later on in the trailer we get another
look at new Asgard and can see that it's
now a thriving Community the several
Cruise Line is there and also a van
advertising new Asgard to it we get a
planet that looks like an MC Asher
painting and I love the way this twists
and turns adding to the complexity of
the world there's also a moment where
Corgan Thor stand together and look over
a downed Beast absolutely love this
moment and it's pulled directly from the
comics namely Thor God of Thunder shows
how much attention to detail they're
paying and it's such a standout moment
in this teaser and we also know that
Russell Crowe has been cast as Zeus and
we catch his back at one point this is
gonna be really interesting and
potentially we could get a Pantheon of
the Gods Moon Knight has introduced
conchu to us and we may end up getting
other ones appearing such as Bass from
Black Panther really nice inclusion to
have them here and I can't wait to see
what they do with the guy and it might
even make him Odin's brother which would
be a nice surprise there's also an
energy conference and potentially this
is a nut to rock song the evil
corporation that letters the Marvel
Universe they have had several
references to them in the MCU but
nothing major I bet this could be where
they come out Valkyrie is seen wearing a
suit at this point and beside her we can
catch Meek wearing one too this looks
quite feminine and in the comics Meek
could have kids so it makes sense now as
for Jane becoming Thor this has a lot of
precedent in the comics in the source
material while still was off world
battling Gore she got diagnosed with
cancer and though she had several
magical options that could have healed
her she refused to take them though
eventually ended up losing his
worthiness is that a word worthiness
anyway and because of this he was unable
to wield mulnier he then started calling
out to Jane and Heimdall took it to
where it had been left behind which just
so happened to be the moon Jane picked
it up and instantly she gained Thor's
powers and this also cured her over
cancer although eventually found her and
now he was a bit like well mate you made
thorough woman bloody bloody outrageous
wokeness this is he gave her his
Blessing when he seen that she was
indeed worthy Thor even handed over his
name and we know from the toilets that
she'll be going by the Mighty Thor at
some point in the film he ended up
falling back on his old name Odin CERN
and I think that's probably what will
also be happening in the film at some
point now one of the big questions you
might have is how is ammonia
pronounce it how is Thor's hammer back
that's obviously because in Thor
Ragnarok it was destroyed by hella which
was really sad because the hammer used
to pull Thor off as for this one though
many people think that it might come
from another dimension like the one in
endgame if we look at the toy leaks we
can see that it's been pieced together
again maybe hella smashed it up and
because you have to be worthy to lift it
the pieces remain behind and thus it was
easy to put back together again as for
how Jenkins lifted I'm not 100 sure but
I have a theory that it might have
something to do with the Infinity Stones
if we look at Vision in Age of Ultron he
could lift it and though it was thought
that this was because he was pure it
might have also been to do with the Mind
stone that brought him to life now Jane
was attached to one two namely the
Aether that shut up and Thor the Dark
World potentially this blowing through
her veins could have been the reason
that she could harness the hammer and
also gain the power of Thor if he cast
your mind back to the fist Thor film
Odin said whoever shall be worthy shall
have the power of Thor so her lifting
this would instantly give her his
abilities now a big missing part of the
trailer is Gore the butcher who we know
is going to be the big bad in the film
like a lot of things in this video we
got our first look at him the toy leaks
but he doesn't show up yet there was a
lot of back and forth over this and from
here on out I'm calling the guy
Christian pale as for the design it's a
big departure from the comics and I'm
actually interested to see where they go
with it the big defense around the whole
thing is that you don't hire Christian
Bell and then hide his face but let me
present to you the Dark Knight trilogy
anyway though it's not really in line
with the comics I think that the design
is kinda creepy the guy looks like anime
did after he got melted in Revenge of
the Sith and I'm getting a lot of evil
monk vibes from him here we also know
from the toilets at the end of his
fingers will be black much in the same
way that agathas were in one division
after she casts Magic from the dark
dimension now this kind of ties into the
overarching theory that I have about
Gore in the necro sword which we also
know he'll be wielding this powerful
weapon is strong enough to butcher a God
whether it also has a darker side to it
wielding a cooker up go throughout the
film and it may start by turning his
fingers black before it moves over his
whole body so the design for the
character is getting a lot of backlash
I'd love to see if it mutated him over
the film and eventually we could get a
version of him that's more in line with
the comics now in case you don't know
the comics pretty much outline his
backstory really really well growing up
he was very religious tying into this
monk idea and Gaul was told that the
gods would Shield him from harm if he
ever prayed to them whether after his
wife and all their children died he
promised to get revenge on the gods and
he sought out a way to kill him one by
one this led him into conflict with Thor
who eventually managed to defeat him
through absorbing his weapon known as
the god bomb Thor labeled him the god of
hypocrisy and though he killed him he
was later resurrected in following
storylines Bale is a massive Gap by the
MCU I can't wait to see what he pulls
off in the movie The Dark Knight trilogy
is probably still the best comic book
Trilogy of all time and it's going to be
great seeing him in this film as for
what happened to his family in the MCU
there's been lots of rumors such as him
being snapped and thus he wasn't there
to protect them according to reports
they all died upon his return but this
might just be BS because hey it's the
internet and anyone can make stuff up
there's also theories that they were
killed by Heller and this would somewhat
set up his Vendetta with Thor with her
being the goddess of death it would also
tine with the necro sword which he may
have obtained from her realm as for my
reaction this first look has got me
really hyped though Ragnarok is in my
top 5 MCU films and I think it's easily
the funniest Marvel movie there is where
TD has gone on to win Oscars for his
directing and I think the guy's got a
really good sense of humor go watch what
we do in the shadows if you haven't seen
it and the comics they're choosing to
take elements from are also really
strong as well and casting Christian
Bale as the villain is something that
people will definitely want to see all
in all this is making for a great movie
and there's such a fun and stylized take
on the whole teaser trailer really fun
to be back with a god of thunder hey and
I hope you enjoyed the breakdown I'd of
course love to hear your thoughts so
make sure you comment below and let me
know if you want something else to watch
then we've got another Marvel breakdown
on screen right now so definitely go
head over there right after this you
better bloody go I'm telling you this
time I don't mind you not liking the
video or subscribing but you better go
to that without the way I'll see you
over there thanks for sticking the video
take care peace